Hey Youtubers it's Charlie this is going to
be my Gotham episode 4 video we finally got
to meet Michael Chiklis and we found a little
bit more about what the is planning for the
city something that may remind you from a
quarter Val storyline also really interesting
fact today in fictional history Batman fought
the Joker for the first time the first issue
he appeared and was Batman number one but
you remember Batman started in detective comics
he didn't start in Batman so happy Batman
verse Joker day today is also like the flash
into world state but that's only on TV not
in the comics listed top five WTF moments
and then I'll explain some of the new characters
from the comics a kind of cuddle what they're
doing with the quarter Val storyline there
just are changing a few things careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode yet
you go starting with number five meet Nathaniel
Barnes new captain played by Michael Chiklis
he's an awesome actor I love it is on the
show if you really want to watch like an awesome
cop drama with Michael Chiklis watch the shield
that was on FX a long time ago as we meet
them in this episode he's not much of a character
yet like we've only just seemed brief bits
of him we we don't really know what's going
on underneath the surface is more like a really
punchy walking megaphone just like yelling
at people think that up on the cake this should
that a you break the law villains arising
the season of course the police are going
to have to match that's of this episode was
kind like the rise of the police in the actually
kinda strayed into Untouchables territory
if you haven't seen it it's this amazing film
about Elliot Ness going after Al Capone out
components played by Robert De Niro Kevin
Costner plays Elliot Ness Sean Connery kinda
plays an older version of detective Gordon
during the film there's this montage were
they going they put their team together like
alcohol Capone seems Untouchables so they
need this awesome team to take them down when
there's Academy is kind like when Andy Garcia
shows up during Untouchables he's at the crack
shot rookie from the Academy like all these
people that they just lined up like you're
way too smart to be here what he would he
doing in the police Seattle silly when a little
over-the-top but I love what they're doing
with the Nathaniel Barnes character of these
can be a lot more entertaining to watch when
we learn more about him on the number for
the meat silver St. Cloud Bruce's special
new friend if it wasn't plainly obvious they're
just trying to present Bruce with Sophie's
choice is he going to choose the Catwoman
path is he going to choose the high society
silver St. Cloud path maybe Silvers gonna
be worse for him the Catwoman who is an actual
criminal so that's saying a lot if you're
worse than an actual criminal she seems relatively
harmless so I'm really interested to see how
complicit she is in theaters plans the misdirect
is to think that just because she's a child
she's innocent which is not the case for me
we met Catwoman we know she's totally not
innocent kids in Gotham can be every bit is
crazy as the adults shout out for poison ivy
in the comics silver St. Cloud showed up in
1977 in detective comics number 470 she wasn't
much of a character than she was around for
Hugo strange storyline then went away for
a long time they brought her back a couple
times that were particularly memorable but
her biggest storyline lately has been widening
Geyer that wasn't super recent that was actually
Kevin Smith Batman stories are that was a
while ago so the most part I'm actually totally
cool with been changing her character from
the comics is not one of those big a list
characters she totally fits in with this quarter
Val storyline so you think of silver St. Cloud
yeah she's kind like sugar I think of it as
a metaphor that Theo is using the sugar to
hide the taste of the poison he's trying to
either win over or neutralize Bruce on the
number three though Theo versus the Penguin
so this is actually interesting scene where
he reveals that big cityscape with some of
his grand plans for Gotham similar to what
was going on with the Arkham city storyline
worth like organ to rebuild got them the way
we wanted to be but in this instance is a
lot closer to what was going on during quarter
bowels but they changed a few things because
during quarter Val's it was Bruce Wayne that
wanted to revitalize Gotham so he presents
Lincoln March who is the mayor of Gotham at
the time with this plan for redesigning Gotham
he shows him a model of Gotham with a bunch
of new buildings to the twisting that make
it more of a sinister thing but the whole
idea is who is going to control the future
of Gotham payroll course is kind of funny
he's one of those characters that just can't
catch a break no matter how powerful he thinks
he is supposed to be the king got them but
he can barely control his minions on top of
that Theo's reaction to him was just so awesome
they just like all you think you're the key
of Gotham how cute is that let me show you
my favorite reality show I am in a really
didn't like that line that was kinda cheesy
but you get the idea he's trying to control
the person who thinks he is controlling everyone
else he's supposed to be Gotham's final boss
form so is Bruce and all the other characters
muscle up they have to defeat all the smaller
villains till they make it to the final boss
James phrase totally amazing is a villain
I've never seen a villain performance of his
that I didn't like but the only thing I'm
not going to get on board with is his American
accent that is using in this is just too weird
I'm not really sure why it's not okay for
him to have a British accent just because
it feels a lot more natural coming out of
his mouth but but I'll give them some time
may meet or maybe a warm-up to a on the number
to the Riddler and Ms. Kringle so this was
mostly fun from a comedy perspective but I
just I want the actor Corey Michael Smith
it plays the river to where this T-shirt that
says the Riddler is my copilot because he
keeps hallucinating that other personality
the actor said that it's not a split personality
so I you I don't know exactly Heather can
explain it but he is definitely not going
anywhere like that's going to continue to
be a thing if you thought that was a lot of
fun like him just being crazy with himself
they're going to continue to develop that
and as nice as regular enigma is none of this
bodes well for Ms. Kringle who is just like
traded one crazy person for another yet to
feel a little bad for her even though it's
nice to see them together I feel like they
will be a good fit so maybe if she becomes
of on eventually that be a lot of fun but
I don't think they're taking her in that direction
the Riddler has had a lot of assistance in
the past but none of them have ascended to
Harley Quinn levels so yay for the two of
them somebody get them the number of an abuse
hotline because Ms. Kringle spry Canadian
to call in a couple episodes finally on my
number one WTF moment more abuse Alfred hits
the cat there are very few things you can
do that are worse than abusing an animal yet
to feel so bad for missing here with the fire
hydrant on the street is just her self-esteem
pouring onto the pavement just sadness everywhere
what is the whole reason for this atrocity
be committed what is the purpose of this will
mostly is the narrative challenging the Catwoman
to make a decision what she's gonna do about
Bruce do you want to be with it like do you
want to be his friend do you want to be romantically
involved with them or do you want to have
nothing to do with them at all she's got to
pick this is West side story all over again
so of course she's going to choose Bruce and
she's going to challenge Alfred she's gonna
stick up for herself they know know know I
can do what I want I can be friends with whoever
I want to be Selena Kyle and Bruce will always
be way more interesting than Bruce with other
characters silver St. Cloud is just temporary
so if you're like really bummed out the Catwoman
got kicked to the curb she'll be back with
a vengeance let me know in the comments though
they were like a couple twist in the plot
that were super obvious be telegraphed especially
with Bruce and silver St. Cloud Catwoman had
he does feel about that and you get upset
when it's too obvious order you kinda pick
up on the idea that they wanted it to be silly
sometimes I get an idea that the characters
on this TV show nose there in a comic book
TV show so they act like comic book characters
would which technically would be accurate
but most TV shows try to play little bit more
real it can be kinda confusing one other comic
book shows play it straight like their comic
book shows where the characters know they're
in a comic book like imagine every single
character acting like Cisco that would be
kinda bad Cisco on the flash is funny because
he's one of the few characters that acknowledges
the comic books exist if every character did
that it be terrible like you have to have
characters reacting to the ridiculous character
but I am really excited to see Michael Chiklis
kicked the ship out of the Penguin because
that's who they're going after first more
animal abuse on Gotham so here's the deal
new episode of the flash tonight it is going
to be crazy make sure you watch it is called
the flash of two worlds they are totally going
full on comic book there's going to be some
iconic comic book moments during the episode
if you ever read the flash to world that was
just the first time in the comics that Barry
Allen met Jay Garrick I will also be starting
a new round of the reverse flash ring giveaway
so lots of stuff happening tonight disengages
haven't seen it there were a whole bunch of
trails that I post the last couple days you
can click here for a bunch of new footage
from arrow the flash it can click here for
the daredevil season two trailer with the
first look at the punisher thank you so much
for watching, everybody high five and I'll
see you guys tonight!